in a fixed mindset people think that
success
is all about talent having the gift a
growth mindset is saying
okay talent obviously matters it's a
factor but it's not enough it's what we
do with our talents i wasn't the best
table tennis player in the world i never
got into the top 20 of the world
rankings
but with that attitude i maximize my own
potential
i think leadership counts when it comes
to innovation i mean the way amazon
conducts meetings
then when they start talking the most
senior person always speaks last
you'll get an unvarnished access to the
insights
of your brilliant team rather than
speaking first and everyone basically
converging on
what you as the leader has just said
there are a lot of people with truly
brilliant ideas
huge potential who never
act on their dreams but having the idea
doesn't mean a thing you've actually got
to act on that idea
honestly i think we shouldn't
underestimate how damaging it can be if
[Music]
matthew syed he's written some of the
most important
challenging thought-provoking books in
the self-development self-improvement
team development team building company
building leadership space
and his ideas are original they are
challenging they are
fresh they are important he was an elite
level sportsman and his ideas come from
the world of sport
but also the world of business from
politics from writing
from culture from society he evangelizes
about
diverse thinking about including more
ideas
about challenging leadership about
challenging yourself
about what it takes to start and why
most people
spend their life sitting on ideas that
could potentially change their life
but are seemingly imprisoned trapped and
blocked
by their own mindset he talks about how
some of the most talented people in the
world
can fall short of their potential and
how some people
with seemingly no talent at all can
achieve miraculous things
if you apply the learnings from this
conversation i have no doubt
that it will make you a better person it
will make your teams more innovative
and it will lead you to living a more
fulfilled life so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
director ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
matthew everyone wants to be successful
everybody i don't know one person that
doesn't want to be successful so i think
it's probably quite important to define
what that word
means under your own definition of that
word the holistic definition not just a
professional
definition but how would you define that
well look it's great to be here steve i
i think that's quite a deep question
quite a philosophical one
really just getting started i know what
kind of opening question is this
i i um obviously as as a former sports
person i was a table tennis professional
for for a number of years
um success was defined in terms of
winning matches
and achieving very uh clear tangible
objectives like winning the national
championships or the
the commonwealth and so the but i think
when it comes to life beyond sport
yeah it's so objective in something like
the 100 meter sprint
you want to be your pb and you can see
it
on a digital readout at the end of a
race how close you've come or whether
you've achieved that objective
in the life beyond sport i have to say
one of the things that is quite
difficult i think for sports people to
transition
is it's more elusive more subjective
more ephemeral and i think it is a
really difficult thing
to define what you personally mean by
success
i'm not 100 sure that i've defined it
for myself yet
have you have you i i well i i'm i'm
getting closer
on a prof in a professional sense i what
i would how i'd answer that question is
i'd say
i think i'm successful if in my
professional life
if i am striving
if i'm taking on a worthwhile challenge
with people i love
so the key terms there are worthwhile
subjective to find out how you like
challenge which i think is um in
integral to
being motivated and getting up in the
morning and you know all the emotions
you need to be
internally uh internally fulfilled and
motivated
and then with people i love which i
think is just a really which speaks to
community and human interaction which i
think is part of our human
yeah and the yeah look that makes a lot
of sense to me i i have to say what one
thing that
given what you've just said you'll
probably agree with i think the narrow
way that success
has sometimes been defined in western
capitalist societies has been
deeply mistaken that it's all about how
much money you have in your bank account
and i think we all know
although you know it's a bit of a cliche
to say that it doesn't provide
happiness certainly not of a sustained
nature
i think that that thing about social
interaction the thing that makes me
happiest for sure
is putting one's heart and soul into a
project
like for example writing a book and then
getting a letter from somebody who
explains
in their own way how it has positively
impacted their life and there is no
feeling like that
for me as a writer and that
really is a powerful engine to motivate
you to come up with a new idea for a new
book
the fact that you know it's having it
has meaning for other people
not that they've paid money to buy it
and that money has been transferred via
a publisher
into my bank account that is much less
significant i mean it's great
if you do get money for it you know you
can look after your kids or you can
do something with it but it's that
feedback that sense of making some kind
of a difference
i mean in a funny kind of a way that
that's why for a long time um
as i came towards the end of my
television squad i wanted to go to
politics i thought that is the place
where you can make the most difference
right you've got the levers
to do something interesting and then i
realized it was
not quite as funner avenue perhaps as
as uh as writing why why is it that
human beings seem to get so much
intrinsic joy
from helping others i think this is a
great and deep significance and you know
just to put a historical lens on this
after the enlightenment the idea was of
human beings as individuals
individualism was the great goal of
political
life and i think we conceived of people
as deciding uh to perhaps interact with
other people
deciding to have families and you might
remember margaret thatcher
once said there's no such thing as
society
there are just individual men and women
and families i mean she had more to say
after that it wouldn't be fair to say
that was her entire philosophy by any
means
i think she was a great prime minister
in many ways
but but if you actually go back deeper
in human history
when we uh our ancestors lived at the
same time as the neanderthals the
neanderthals had
probably bigger brains than us they may
have been individually smarter
but humans lived in tighter more
socially connected groups what does that
mean
it means if somebody learns something
useful they can share it
with one of their kin and therefore
they can also share it with their
children they can get a
cross-pollination of ideas they can
bring ideas together
and then it gets passed down the
generations and it was that
sociality that conferred a competitive
advantage
on our ancestors above neanderthals
it's it is i think our distinctive
quality
we are social beings to an extent
greater i think than any others except
the
insects like uh ants who for slightly
different uh evolutionary reasons
cooperate at scale
and there's an element of virtue
signaling
social media that sort of seems to have
exacerbated this amongst our my
generation in particular who all seem to
want to change the world
but can't necessarily tell you what they
want to change they just want to be a
person that's changed the world
that's interesting that's interesting
because about a decade ago i started
looking at you know
now i'm i'm believe it or not 50. uh
he's a little great
well i was going to say i don't if you
have to remember oil of are you late
no that's probably the slightly older
people will remember i don't use that by
the way but
um i uh started looking at how
aspirations have changed since i was in
my choice so when i was at university
everyone wanted to work for the u.n
yeah that was kind of considered the
great
sort of panacea of life but 10 years ago
a lot of people were saying in surveys
of young people
what do you want to do in life what do
you want to be in life and the answer
was
famous yeah famous you know not not to
have a body of work
that gives you fame you know to walk to
you know you want to walk down the red
carpet having created an amazing film
but no
they just wanted the red carpet and i
thought that was that was a dangerous
thing and i i'm sure there's been a
correction since then but i think the
obsession
there's been no correction and i think
in some respects it's got worse i've
just it's a real phenomenon i've noticed
in my generation where
after i'll come off stage doing a public
speech whatever
kids will come up to me and say i want
to be a public speaker too
i never wanted to be i pursued my desire
to start a business and a byproduct of
that
was they pay me to speak on stage now
and fame also in my view should be a
byproduct of the pursuit of something
that's intrinsically
important to you right absolutely 100
correct and that's why the obsession
with fame is a massive danger i think to
uh
to a culture um the the thing about
speaking
so so a completely unintended side
effect of writing my first book so i'm
finishing table tennis and i'm like you
know what am i going to do with the rest
of my life
uh you know how am i going to define
success and i decided to write this book
in 2000
when does it come out 2010 called bounce
yes and i said this side effect was
being invited to give a speech at a big
corporation an investment bank an
american investment bank
and obviously you know as an
ex-ping-pong player
i'm thinking what is going on here you
know how am i suppo imposter syndrome
and also you know i went to a school i
went to a comp you know we didn't do any
almost no public speaking you know we we
learn
stuff we learn things in the classroom
but the idea of getting up in
and speaking in front of an audience was
kind of very alien
so i wasn't that good right because i
hadn't practiced that i'd never
done it before and i came off the stage
and i thought
you know what i'm just not cut out for
this if i'm invited again to give a talk
to a company i'll just politely decline
then i thought and it took me about i
know 48 hours to think what a ridiculous
way to hijack my own development if you
actually had the right attitude if you
had the right mindset
you can probably learn these skills and
take advantage of these brilliant
opportunities because you always learn
don't you when you go and speak in an
organizer
so i googled public speaking practice
and the first hit was called
toastmasters and this is like a global
network of just
public speaking clubs where other normal
people um
go to the club to develop social
confidence and the one nearest me in
richmond was in twickenham
just over the bridge and there was uh
franco worked at lloyd's on the high
street
just the group you give a speech they'd
give you feedback
and the mentoring was a really important
part of it because you need a bit of
feedback
and you know what you could have done
better and then about two-thirds of the
way through there's something called
table topics
where somebody writes the list of topics
on cards
but no one else in the room knows what
they are so you have to go to the front
you pick it up and then turn around
and spontaneously talk for a minute on
whatever topic the first one i ever did
was the natural history museum
you know that's terrifying right you're
not used to it but you learn and you
develop that skill
um so so learning how to speak publicly
it took me three or four years and i'm
not saying i'm brilliant at it now by
any means but my goodness how much
better when you have a can-do
attitude towards it and that brings us
to the topic of mindset
really nicely you know i've heard you
talk about having a growth mindset and a
fixed mindset what is the difference
between the two
so i think for thank you for what it's
worth i think this contrast is
is so important i mean i can talk about
it through my own life but
you know in a fixed mindset people think
that success
however defined is all about talent
having the gift
uh having the genetic inheritance and
you know having the personality trait in
order to excel
a growth mindset is saying okay talent
obviously matters it's a factor
but it's not enough it's what we do with
our talents so people in a fixed mindset
have two
massive risks one they think they're so
talented they don't even need to try
so think of a young person who's just
been
invited to join the manchester united
academy
and they're suddenly getting money into
their bank account they're able to buy
the fast car
and they think i'm god's gift and they
and the amount of academy coaches who
have come to me and said we don't
understand it we had this hard-working
youngster we invited them into the
academy
and then they just went off the rails
it's a fixed mindset they think their
success is the short so they stop
putting in the hard yards and don't
transition
into the first team so that's one danger
the other danger
is people who don't think they're god's
gift but
like me at goldman sachs you make one
failure
and you interpret that as meaning i
obviously don't have talent therefore
i'm just going to give up
you see what i mean yeah so that's the
negative version yeah so you've got the
i'm super talent is everything and i've
got it so therefore i don't need to try
talent is everything
i don't have it therefore i should give
up they're both terribly
uh damaging i think a growth mindset it
doesn't mean that we think we're all
going to be the best speaker in the
world
i wasn't the best table tennis player in
the world i never got into the top 20 of
the world rankings
but with that attitude i maximize my own
potential
and going back to your thing about
success
that's not a bad definition now i think
about it you know to try and be the best
that we can be
in our own lives doesn't mean we're
going to be the best who ever lived
you know not everyone could be muhammad
ali or serena williams or
or who or albert einstein but to be the
best we can be i think it's so wonderful
and just from my own perspective i think
trying to fill one's own potential going
on a journey that has some meaning
there's something wonderfully um
uplifting something satisfying about
that too
i really like the combination of those
two ideas this idea of being the best
you can be
but realizing that it's a pursuit
towards something that you may never get
to
right so the journey and the journey
towards being the best you can be at
something which has a lot of meaning to
you
maybe maybe that's the definition we
were looking for now i think that that
point you make about the journey is
really really important what was it i
think it was robert louis stevenson said
to travel is a better thing than to
arrive
oh yeah and in a weird kind of way i can
say i talked about trying to win the
nationals but
first of all in the nationals i remember
winning going home i was living on my
own in a flat in
richmond i got home and i thought is
that it you know what i mean it was
the the fun was actually the training
and the
camaraderie with my practice partners
and seeing those small improvements
through time
i mean that's consistent with most high
performance athletes and
um business people and i was reading
this piece and i think it was in the
telegraph about
um olympic depression where you have the
olympians who train for the olympics
they
and whether they get a gold medal like
michael phelps who fell into depression
or whether they lose either way the
outcome is they just
lose orientation in their life yeah and
and this is why i i and also i felt it
myself when
a company came along when i was 24 and
offered to buy my company and i go home
look at right move look at all the cars
i can buy and everything
and i feel this sense of emptiness and
like but then what what's my life
without this
and genuinely that was like an
existential crisis because i was like
i can't sell this thing but the insecure
broke kid in me
thought he was doing this to sell this
thing yeah and it was just this really
you know
it's one i think one of the deep
paradoxes of the human mind i mean
the the sense of anti-climax
when one achieves a long cherished
ambition i want to be a millionaire i
want to buy an aston martin
i want to win the olympic gold medal i
remember talking to victoria pendleton
oh yeah the olympian yeah because you
lit the cyclist
you know you live with this ambition
it's what gets you out of bed
in the morning right i want to win the
olympic gold it's what
when you're on the track she was
explaining you know it's what makes you
push harder
because you've got this this goal this
destination
that's pulling you this magnet pulling
you towards it
then when you get it you wake up the
next day and what on earth is getting
you out of bed
what's causing you to push yourself
that's one of the reasons i think people
who make money very quickly
face massive many not all
and this is well documented psychology i
mean you'll know about the
people who win lotteries whose marriages
can
end who end up in in often depression i
mean that's not a cliche this is well
established
and i think it's because you get
something and then it's like
what is left to pursue in life
i do some interviews for the time sports
stars and i mentioned victoria pendleton
billy jenkins yeah exactly the same
um uh david beckham
um uh ryan giggs
uh i mean i've interviewed you know most
of the the
ronaldo most of the leading many of the
leading sports people and it's the same
story and
i think what i've noticed is that
as you did that capacity to take a step
back
and to say you know what i'm feeling low
feeling empty
i need to find something else that's
gonna galvanize me and
and that's what gets people back on and
i think the antidote
is being aware of that yeah and
because then now when i achieve things
in my life i don't come into those
achievements with this expectation of
exponential joy
and so i can almost enjoy it more
right you know yeah no i totally get
that i i
trying to think you know yeah i think
look just
one of the things that i've noticed from
my own personal lives the more busy i've
got
sometimes you don't take enough time to
take a step back
and to say you know this was a great
thing that happened or
or to be in the moment when something is
happening with
one dude do you have kids no no with
with one's children or
wife or partner or whatever and i think
i'm slowly
you know i write books on this stuff but
i i i'm learning all the time
and that's one of the reasons i want to
do the podcast when i've read about you
i thought you've had
such a different set of experiences to
me i'll learn a lot from you too
we've now had two subscribers come in
and watch from behind the scenes we're
going to start picking more so all
you've got to do if you want that to be
you
is hit the subscribe button let's talk
about failure than something you talk
about at great length
i think um tend to believe that a lot of
the reason why people don't reach their
potential
however we define that is because they
are risk adverse
and failure is something they just can't
their self-esteem just can't bear
i think that's i think that's true my
own sense is that this has been
exacerbated
by the social media so you tell me how
the social media it may have changed a
lot since i
wrote my first book for young people but
at the time
psychologists had come up with this
concept of the curse of perfectionism
and their thesis was
that young people are obviously now on
the social media a lot
and a lot of people when they're putting
together their social media posts they
do it in such a way as to make their
lives look really good
you know this is the holiday i just had
on this wonderfully sunny beach
and um you know they might even airbrush
photos to make themselves look better
and this is my wonderful performance on
the piano and and the problem is
people then start to think that success
is about looking
and acting in a perfect way that's
massively problematic because why would
you want to try anything new
which is inherently a risk because if
you're doing something the first time
you're obviously not going to be perfect
um and if you do mess up you draw the
thing that goes back to the fixed
mindset you draw the conclusion well i'm
obviously not
talented enough because i haven't nailed
it the first time around i think this
was also bolstered by
in your own reality television now i
think reality tell the idea of
instant success instant gratification
overnight elevation into in into the
heavens
and if you you know particularly young
people think that success is like that
they don't realize the incremental steps
you need to take to fulfill your
potential because as you know
most businesses succeed because you know
i don't know whether you're familiar
with the american jargon but you get a
minimum viable product you test the
value proposition early you find out the
inevitable deficiencies in the prototype
or the piece of software
and then you make adaptations in silicon
valley they call it failing fast in
other words they're failing fast in
order to get to a better answer
if you stop the first time you fail or
if you don't try at all you're never
going to get to an answer
if you think of the history of science
science is a success the most successful
human institution
because scientists by and large are
willing to test their hypotheses
you know they test it they look at the
empirical evidence and they change it in
the light of what the evidence is
telling them
that is the basic pattern of science and
and i think the problem is as he alluded
to is that if young people are like
goodness me i don't want to look
anything other than
perfect it destroys their capacity to
grow and and to have
a life of fulfillment because jk rowling
put it brilliantly she said
the only way never to fail is never to
try but then your life is a failure
because you've just stayed in your
comfort zone the whole time
i see that i resonate with all of that
so much and there's specifically this
this idea i love the science analogy
because
seeing it as a hypothesis you write in
science you you start with hypothesis
you're not romantic about it
and then you go in pursuit and you you
agnostically go and test it
right whereas what you're saying is you
know
young people or ambitious people
generally will start with a hypothesis
and they will long in need for it to be
perfectly incorrect and this is also why
businesses fail because
founders just they just do everything
and i i failed in my first business
for many years because of that because i
was
obsessed romantic about my hypothesis
being correct
not romantic about the outcome which was
trying to be a successful person
right look i i think i think that's
really
really significant and i think that's a
great great way of framing it look
by the way some scientists fall in love
with their theories yeah
and they can't adapt it i mean there's
been a few examples during the pandemic
um and and by the way i mean i don't
know listen there's an interest in this
but
there's a brilliant study by philip
tetlock who's an american psychologist
and he looked at forecasters
so people trying to predict next year's
gdp or oil price or other things of this
kind and he found a really interesting
pattern
that the highest reputation forecasters
who are on television the most
on average make the worst predictions
and can you see what
what is an error of ego an error of
prediction is an opportunity to adapt
the model in order to make it more
predictive in the long run
but if you've been on the tv and you're
supposed to be the god of forecasting
you start defending your prior
assumptions
and so people who have an ego that gets
in the way of hypothesis testing
they are brilliant at creative
self-justification
i think the people who are most
dangerous to companies
and innovation are intelligent highly
talented people in a fixed mindset
they're just inveterate obstacles
to making the changes you need to change
in order to get the business to where
you want to go
to or where you want the economic model
to get to
and so on so i think it's the same in
meetings you know i've
as you know i'm very interested in how
how businesses succeed and the the forum
in which we take
most key decisions are meetings because
no one person has a monopoly on truth so
you want to talk to other people
but these can be really ineffective if
people
think that when someone challenges you
they're insulting you
they're not they're testing your
hypothesis we should think of meetings
as mutual hypothesis testing so that we
can collectively get to the best
uh strategy or idea and i think when you
frame it in that way you take the stigma
out of
challenge and dissent and failure
let's challenge that then so if if we've
got a meeting we've got
five 10 people around this table we've
got an intern over there
uh we've got the ceo there got managers
directors around the table
one new person one person's been here
for 10 years you've got all these
different sort of dynamics of people
trying to
get promotions get a payroll oh my god
the ceo's at the table i don't wanna be
an idiot
i don't wanna say anything dumb you know
and all of those like dynamics how do
you
get those dynamics out of the way and
just become focused on
letting the best idea win right so this
is really well studied
um i think the thing to to try and
really convey
is how dangerous the dynamics you've
described can be
because what tends to happen in a very
hierarchical organization
where the ceo or the team leader has
discretion over pay and promotion is
that people don't say what they think
they say what they think the leader
wants to hear
that's fine if the leader knows
everything there is to know because
you're just basically ventriloquizing
but so in a simple environment
you don't need to have a team right you
just have the leader make a decision and
everyone
but when it's a difficult complex
decision in other words the ones that
confer a competitive advantage on a
business the leader needs to hear
the different perspectives to make a
better judgment but the extent to which
this happens a good example is in
aviation
so i'll describe a classic case in
in the aviation is a great area to study
by the way when it comes to team
dynamics
so this is united airlines 173
and it's a flight that took off out of
uh denver colorado
in december 1978 and it's flying to
portland in oregon
and as a plane's coming in on the final
approach the pilot pulls the lever to
lower the landing gear and you know when
you're in the cabin
you hear it go down and clicks into
place
but on this occasion there's this really
loud bang the plane kind of
deviates and the light that should
illuminate on the dashboard to show that
the wheels are down it hasn't gone on
so the pilot doesn't know if the wheels
are down it's pitch black so they can't
ask
air traffic control to look up so he
puts the plane into a holding pattern
above suburban portland
then they try and troubleshoot the the
issue so the first thing is the engineer
so in these days the cockpit had a
captain a co-pilot and an engineer
the engineer goes into the cabin and on
this particular model of aircraft when
the wheels are down two bolts shoot up
above the wings
the bolts are up but they're still not
100 sure right and you want to know if
the wheels are down
before you come in so so the pilot they
they radio to the manufacturer and that
you know they're kind of
explaining what's happened the
manufacturer is like yeah we think the
wheels are down but we're not sure
then the pilot's like i wonder if the
reason that the light didn't go on the
dashboard is because of faulty wiring
so he starts playing around with with
the in the plane still in the holding
pattern
as they're doing all of these different
checks but at this point another
safety critical issue has come into play
the plane's running out of
fuel right and the engineer
knows that the plane is running out of
fuel because he can see it
going down to zero on the dials right
he has a big incentive to tell the pilot
that the plane is running out of fuel
because otherwise he will die so you
have this juxtaposition
of objective information and maximum
incentive
but in the 1970s it was a command and
control
culture you know the pilot was genomic
yeah the pilot was
deemed to be the boss the omniscient
um controller and the other two were
supposed to basically
carry out that controller's instructions
and they called the pilot sir
it was almost always a man right and and
so imagine if the engineer says to the
pilots
now why do we have a team we have a team
because no one person has
all of the information they're narrow in
their perceptual bandwidth other things
are happening at the same time
but if the engineer says to the pilot
you know what we're running out on pu
of fuel the implication is the pilot
didn't know that already the pilot might
get offended
isn't he supposed to know everything and
we know
from this and many other incidents that
in that situation
we don't speak to each other directly we
don't test hypotheses directly we code
our language we mitigate
our speech and from the voice recorder
from the black box
we know that the engineer said instead
of we need to land because we're running
out of fuel
critical information for the pilot to
make the right strategic decision
he said oh we're kind of getting low on
fuel here
and the pilot because of the insinuation
he knows everything wasn't even
listening
so the plane crashes but not just that
plane a number of
incidents in the 1970s of exactly the
same kind happened
because communication was so skewed by
this very steep hierarchy it happens in
surgical
operating theaters famously when nurses
can't speak up
because they're worried if i say
something this is the surgeon
you know the the the big cheese and
we know from you know for what it's
worth from randomized control trial
evidence lee thompson at northwestern
university meetings are a catastrophe
the vast majority of them
absolute disaster because people are not
sharing information they're basically
playing a political game to curry favor
with the boss so what you so that so the
short answer is you need what's called
psychological safety
it's i hate the jargon all that means is
an environment where everyone feels they
can be
candid and they can say what they really
think
and hypotheses are tested when google
did a big data analysis of his
most successful software development
teams psychological safety was
the biggest predictor of success
because it means you're getting that
interplay of ideas that's so important
it's interesting because you know these
big companies well big companies by
by definition i guess have more ideas
right but they are often the least
innovative exactly
and that seems like a bit of a it should
be the other way around you would one
would think that the biggest companies
would be the most innovative because
they have more brains more ideas but
they're just
that's what yeah yeah that's interesting
point you make there so big
you're right so a bit so well let's
think about that
what would generate good ideas it's the
number of ideas
not the number of people if you have an
organization
with a very homogenous culture very
commanding control
a lot of sociological convergence you
might have 10
000 people all thinking the same way i
mean you've seen professional services
companies where you see the senior
leadership team
and they may look a bit different but
they're all absolutely thinking exactly
the same way they've been there so long
that's a big danger for companies see
with cities you increase the size of
cities they become more innovative
companies get less innovative because
they get so much convergence
they have a lot of people but they think
in the state it's an echo chamber
basically right
whereas startups sometimes
a startup might be an idea that's
completely off the beaten track and then
suddenly you've got this
opportunity to scale but even with
startups you know often when they go
public they start to lose their capacity
to
to innovate and i think that's why you
know i've written a book on it you need
a culture of diversity so that you begin
to protect
and and and value the
um like the diverse ideas that enable an
organization to anticipate future
disruptions and come up with new
talk to me about creating a culture of
diversity in your
in your business then if you're starting
a company if you're running a company at
scale how do you increase the diversity
of
right ideas yes so um so the
the most important for me the most
important thing by far
is landing the argument as to why it
matters
a lot of people don't think it matters i
mean i remember going to an hr
conference and the
the the speaker
was talking about diversity is a
wonderful thing you've all
need more of it and it will always help
you do better as an organization
and this really awkward customer at the
back said can i ask a question and uh
like yeah okay
um imagine i am the coach
of an olympic sprint relay team yeah and
suppose
um i've got you said who was the fastest
person in the world at the time was
usain bolt
suppose i've got usain bolt in my team
and suppose
hypothetically i had cloning technology
so i could clone usain bolt to have four
usain bolts in my four by 100 relay team
there's no diversity in that team but
they're all very fast
right yeah if you said you need to
diversify your team
that would mean hiring slower runners i
don't want to do that as an olympic
coach
and it was like the air in the room just
it's like it'd been punctured and
everyone was like that's an
awful thing but he was right that
question was
you know in simple activities cognitive
diversity of opinion cognitive diversity
doesn't help you if it's obvious what to
do
why would you want diversity if you've
already got a solution a can solution
you just need to scale it you don't need
diver
but when there's a complex environment
that logic
turns on its head so if you imagine for
example
you've got five people each one of whom
has
one brilliant idea you might think you
have five brilliant ideas but if they
all have the same idea you've only got
one
yeah all you need is two different ideas
and suddenly you've
tripled 300 increase in the creativity
of that group
that's where cognitive diversity matters
and if your
mission is to solve complex problems
diversity
is the cornerstone of how well you do it
and once you land that argument people
start to
at the moment people say too many people
think
diversity is a politically correct box
ticking exercise
and when diverse voices come in they're
condescended to they're not properly
included
once you realize it's a strength
organization start to harness it
to do the great things that they want to
do i can imagine that organizations
don't
typically organizations don't know what
they don't know and they don't
they don't know what they don't have as
well so if you don't see what i mean
it's like an unknown i know
so when the board when he's like let's
say we've got six
white six-year-old board members sat
around a table of a
company that's really successful and
then they go
you know what's their incentive to hide
they think we've been doing great
we're all very smart you smart yeah i'm
smart yeah you smart yeah i'm smart
yeah and like how do you make the case
to them that
they need to hire a black woman and
that's going to help
when they've just been killing the game
with these six white men right
well it's okay so again you're
absolutely right to ask the question it
depends on the context yeah
let's say for example the organization
is
uh an advertising company and they've
traditionally been selling to
white middle-aged men who uh think
rather as they do the the
if they only want to sell to white men
then there may be no advantage
in hiring somebody with a different
perspective if they're seeking to
broaden their capacity
to sell to people from different
demographics they won't have the tacit
knowledge that they need in order to do
if you think of the cia they hired
brilliant analysts in the post-war
period and they thought they were the
best
intelligence agency in the world but a
lot of the information was
obviously confidential it's only now we
can see how awful they were because
almost
everyone almost 100 of their analytical
team were white
middle class west coast
anglo-saxon protestant
liberal arts graduates nothing wrong
with that background right
but if you're trying to assess threats
emerging from around the world
the soviet union how would you possibly
understand the probability of
a conglomeration of different nations
falling apart
if you've been brought up in a stable
middle class family in america
how are you going to understand tribal
sectarianism and the risks of
radicalization
in the middle east when you come from
that background you know when we invaded
when when the the the uk joined the
coalition to invade iraq you know there
was a genuine view that you impose
democratic institutions and it will work
effectively there was no real
understanding
of the history of iraq and how those
institutions would be hijacked by
sectarian interests because these
guys had gone to university they'd
learned all sorts of interesting things
but they had no deep
understanding of the dynamics in that
country so
if i was talking to the for example the
director general the cia
i would be explaining you know what you
know
but in the complex world there's stuff
that you don't know there's stuff that
people
who think like you don't know be
creative about how you
optimize the diverse insights that can
help you do the job you want to do
now if it was the cia demographic
diversity is critical
you need to have people from different
backgrounds who have had different
experiences in order to understand
emerging threats
for an advertising team it would be
different for a team of economic
forecasters i can tell you what it would
look like mathematically you want
highly accurate individual forecasters
whose models
generate diverse predictions because
when you average them you get an
incredibly
it's called the wisdom of the crowds so
there are ways to do it i mean there are
tools that we use with our clients to
make this
work and for what it's worth the really
you know
obviously slightly self-serving thing to
say but i think most of the innovative
organizations are thinking exactly what
you've just said
we need to figure out what it is that we
don't know quickly
have some tenuous sense so we can start
plugging these blind spots
right and on that point of
innovation which we touched on what are
the so
running a business running a global
business as it scaled i could see that
we were getting less innovative you kind
of get complacent
you build teams you get you know your
teams get more comfortable with
how it's always been done and then just
getting them to disrupt themselves
becomes increasingly difficult
especially when more people get involved
things seem to slow down someone goes on
and you'll leave
and then you say you've got a new
innovative idea you put it on an email
thread it stumbles around the email for
thread for four months
nobody's incentivized to do that because
they're all getting paid to do their
current job and you don't typically have
like an innovation
team so when it's everybody's job it's
nobody's job these are all probably you
know and then these are
then you talk about failure as well
people aren't incentivized to fail in
big
organizations what are the parameters or
the factors or the dynamics
of a team that does innovate
so i think i look i think that's all
right and i i think it's a bandwidth
issue i mean you talked about a team
that's been successful thus far i mean
to take the legal
profession which have you know used the
billable hour for a very long time
have done a particular and they're busy
and they're making money
but i hope that it's not a particularly
unique insight to say that many of these
legal firms will be out of business in a
decade if they don't leverage machine
learning
right and ai in all sorts of different
ways
and start to disrupt their own so you
can carry on being busy
whilst your equity value is about to
disappear right
so unless one is able to say not just
we need to be doing things well for our
clients
and doing what we've always done
effectively but we need to also be
thinking about how we do things
differently and better
you may well be busy you may well have
satisfied customers but it just takes
one competitor to innovate and you're
out of the game
so i think that that is a good way to
focus minds
on sparing some bandwidth to that
question of innovation
so it doesn't just get dropped it's
tough right because
that often means a change in personnel
yeah and nobody likes that idea
in big organizations i think this about
some of the big advertising groups like
they call them the big six
and the big six have been around some of
them one of them in particular has been
around for a hundred years doing
advertising
what are the big things like wpp
publicis those kind of yeah
and i was thinking you know in their
executive teams you've got people that
have been there for
20 30 years then this thing called
social media comes along
and they're thinking oh my god so it's
not billboards anymore on tv
um where does that leave me and i'm not
gonna know what tick tock and snapchat
are
and the threat of having to replace
oneself i think often
and your ego often um means that you go
down with the titanic
yeah and you know for what it's worth
you see this in in um
in in many different areas so i think i
don't do you admire amazon as a company
admirer yeah i mean in some ways not in
others
yeah so they should pay more taxes yeah
yeah
but i mean what they've done is just
staggering right but i mean i think
so i think leadership counts sometimes
when it comes to innovation
i mean he's obviously no longer um ceo
but i think
if you read jeff bezos's letters to
shareholders they're all about
the stuff that we've been talking about
experimentation unbelievable
commitment um you know we talked about
the meetings you know dissent
and then commit um almost all of the
i mean the way amazon conduct meetings
you know
they will as you know they'll they'll
read the the agenda item in silence
so that every single person is bringing
an independent perspective to bear on
what are the risks of this what might
make it how could it be improved what
might make it
fail and then when they start talking
the most senior person
always speaks last you'll get an
unvarnished
access to the insights of your brilliant
team
rather than speaking first and everyone
basically converging on
what you as the leader has just said so
they have a range of ways of trying to
ensure they sustain
but you know amazon will will probably
struggle but they've done well
so far and it's it's i think it's a good
case study of how to
how to sustain it but it's not i mean
but i i've got to say honestly
one of the things that i'm most
interested in is you know i mentioned
i'm 50.
i'm totally bewildered by social media
and you obviously you
you inhabit right that world you know it
you've got a nuanced
granular understanding of the whole
thing yes imagine you're me
right so now what do you know
i i don't know i don't i don't have the
faintest idea of how
to youthfully engage with the social i
came to twitter late my tweets are
rubbish
i mean look if anyone's following me
thank you but i know i'm not very good
at it but i
it's an alien world for me and i'm not
i've never been on facebook
speaking sorry so we're speaking right
so what should i do how do i
learn how did you learn to speak
toastmasters
well it's a similar thing but it isn't
though because is it yeah
it's i when i did my first public talk
when i was 14
and i'm i always say this i was i was
speaking in front of like parents
evening
my i'm shaking my hands are sweating so
much in this paper shaking so much
i realize i'm not gonna be able to read
the piece of paper because it's moving
too much so i just made up the speech
and it's a similar thing with twitter
you just said i've done my first tweet
awful tweets
and then you're like it sounds like you
quit or you stop oh you were
disappointed still there but i don't do
it very much
because i kind of i i say that i've
probably done a few thousand tweets but
i came to it late and i
i still feel that if you
okay let me ask you this if you had to
summarize what you know
yeah about the social media and and how
one
engages with it how one you know one
wants one's
articles to be read you know how would
is it impossible to encapsulate that in
a minute
i would say so i so what i do
professionally
what i used to do professionally is i'd
go and do these talks telling people all
about social media
all the tips tricks techniques
algorithms
all the psychology and really explaining
it to them and then i'd end my talk by
telling them that everything i've just
told them
probably won't be the case in three to
six months because it changes so much
and and what that therefore means is the
only way to know what i know
is to play with the toy as often as you
can and it's and so from this is why i
say to people when they come up to me
and say how do i become a social media
expert
i say to them often like we'll name
something you're interested in they'll
go you know
i don't know cars i'll say go make a car
instagram page and run it
because then it puts you in the trenches
and it makes it puts you in
a growth moment or so
and it's just practice and it's that's
all it is so if you want to become a
master of this thing that's constantly
changing and there's ten updates to the
top
um four social media apps every single
week
then you have to have a reason to be
showing
you've have that life has to be giving
you a reason to show up every day
and open it up and look at it and and
perform these iterative
uh tests which give you this feedback
loop so for me
the real savior for me as a social media
ceo and most of the things i went on to
sell to clients
were learnings that i got from two
places the first is um in my company i
create this thing called ever changing
landscape
very very simple internal group
everybody shares everything they know
every day
oh my god i've just seen tick tock have
launched this new button goes into the
group
we then text it to all of our employees
at 9 am in the morning every morning on
whatsapp
so and it's this constant loop of what's
new what's changing
our mantra as a company became keeping
brands at the forefront of what's
possible
and what but that slogan appreciates the
fact that there's a
marketing director [ __ ] themselves
because it's changing every day
and they want to be at the forefront of
what's possible but they're [ __ ] so
it feels like
two jigsaw pieces i'm [ __ ] myself
because this thing's changing
you're saying you're gonna keep me at
the forefront of what's possible which
is gonna make me look good to the ceo
we're gonna work with social chain and
the second thing that kept me at the
very forefront and made me good at
social media
is i run my personal brand on social
media
which means that on linkedin instagram
twitter
every day i'm either tweet and i've got
a team that helped me now but i'm
tweeting i'm looking at the numbers
doing a post looking in the comments
okay that didn't go well click on the
insights button
loads of people seem to share this one
why is that ah maybe that's because
there's eight posts and
okay the subtitles oh my god look at the
retention number when we did subtitles
yeah the retention so much higher click
on the insights oh my god look so when
we do that at the start of the video
80 of people fall off in the first five
seconds of all of my videos
so i've got to do something special in
the first five seconds and it's that
constant learning over 10 years
then people call you as a expert it's
not i just been playing with a toy
longer yeah and that that i mean
it's great to hear you say that because
i think that's the pattern of
learning in pretty much all fields every
field in all aspects of life
yeah i mean that's science right you're
getting the iterative feedback exactly
and the more granular the feedback i
mean if you know
that people are switching off the video
after five seconds or ten seconds
better than just knowing yeah that 50
dropped off over the total time so
so it's the granularity and speed and
objectivity of that feedback so playing
with do you think that um
so you may think this is a cop-out but
say you're you know it is me now trying
to get
if you if you're a writer yeah and you
obviously got a lot going on
yeah in terms of coming out with the new
but do you think it's outsourcing i mean
obviously you can
you could outsource it to a brilliant
person to do you could outsource it to a
brilliant person to do
a lot of charlatans a lot of snakehole
salesmen so it's fine how do you know
what's good when you don't know what's
good
well that's one of the reasons well i've
as it happens
i have tried to do that and i've had a
number of proposals there that i'll
check with you
okay that's what we'll do in exchange
i'll help you find someone that that is
actually good
um that's the quid pro quo right you
could have a lovely
what i would say is you can learn one
channel one or two channels
with no matter how busy you are um and
if you do learn one or two channels the
impact it will have
on your business your as an author as a
as
as a you know someone that um shares
their ideas with the worlds and
creates blogs is tremendous you only
have to learn one or two channels better
than 95 percent of people
and to do that you just need to use it
every other day and if i was you i'd be
thinking
twitter i'd be thinking
it depends medium is an interesting one
i'm going to give you three twitter
linkedin and medium i wouldn't bother
with instagram if i was you
if you're a writer and you're your your
the audience that you speak to with the
ideas you convey
linkedin twitter super easy to learn
and i i know that sounds like really of
course i'll say that because
like but those two platforms i think
will have a
exponential impact on your business
that's interesting so probably i i
so somebody in my office handles the
linkedin
and and instagram but i've i've not
really been on them enough and learned
so
this is really really really helpful do
you think that social media
has been a force for good in the world
because
it's difficult i mean i don't know if
you you've been following the news on
that the last week you probably have the
last 48 hours
but i see you know we talked a bit
earlier about how
we can converge with people who think
the same as us and we've obviously seen
that on
certain types of social media where you
get these echo chambers
trump trump the filter bubble other
things of that kind but at the same time
you have access if you want it to lots
of different voices and people in
certain types of societies can blow
whistles or things that are going wrong
you know i i think the the the political
consequences of the social media
are among the most important of my
lifetime
um i obviously am not a native and
you know i have a particular analysis
what's your take on that
so the great things to come from social
media the first things that spring to
mind
are important ideas being shared at
scale and change happening faster than
it ever possibly could have
so you think about key movements around
lgbtq rights
um you think about certain causes you
think about
atrocities happening in certain parts of
the world having a window into those
things and those ideas spreading very
quickly
and the consensus being arrived that
quickly therefore actually been taken
quickly therefore changing political
change happenings at
light speed i think is amazing um i
think
one could say being able to make
some type of connection with people in
faraway lands
however on the adverse consequences of
social media the biggest ones for me
are um the the things like instagram
which create which will ultimately lead
you to believing that you're a piece of
[ __ ] and not enough
and how does it do that because
everyone's life looks so good everyone's
amazing
um so that does happen on instagram of
course yeah i mean the algorithm will
show you
um the prettiest people typically
typically the prettiest people
that have the best lives and then
obviously there's this
almost like black mirror-esque ranking
where if i post a selfie and i'm not
looking on my a-game
i'll get less likes so that's like the
the world's going um
five by ten steve today and then i come
back with the filter
and i'm posing and i've done a little
photoshop here and the face tune here
and i come back look at my fake stuff
and it was instagram
oh well done and then it's incentivizing
me
it's you know positively reinforcing me
to live a more fake
more shallow more materialistic life
that's so interesting and and people do
you know they change their phones to
look better i write about this in my
book the the ceo of
an app called facetune said that
um facetune is basically an app that
allows you to very easily without any
editing skills change completely how you
look
you can change your skin color that make
you
make your face have no spots on it you
can suck your face in your hips in and
it
it's so easy to do and um
and on top of and so the ceo of that
company said that he hit a gold mine and
he says openly he says i it was just a
gold mine
the amount of downloads that app has had
from young people who want to change how
they look
is staggering then you have this other
thing now with which with these face
filters where i can put a filter on
and it will just clear my skin up and
suck my face in just a little bit
and now people you know people can't
operate without them i think i'm
probably guilty of it too if i can just
press this button and it's going to
increase my prospects of dating
and i'm going to go back to the stuff if
you don't tell me you're having problems
getting
data i mean that i can't well actually
people can't see you
you've been on it he's been on here oh
has it he's a great guy but he was like
all these that's the two sort of iconic
young entrepreneurs
but this thing about instagram is really
really interesting
really interesting so you think it is
actually
incentivizing people
constructing there is no way it isn't if
you so let me give you some more
information on this so um when
when they did a stack this vast report
on which social platforms
having the most adverse impact on young
people's mental health instagram was
stand out it's a visual platform which
is um
ranking you on how you look and the
algorithm will show you the richest
smart the richest most beautiful most
successful people
you've got the kardashians on there with
150 million followers who are
literally have been in the last couple
of months um
been like a paparazzi person took the
photo
of them on the beach and then you got to
see what they posted
and it's they don't look the same and
you've got 100 million girls
following this person who is lying about
the fact that they don't have cellulite
and
they're not a normal you know because
this is these are normal things we all
have you know
cellulite and this and this and the
rasher and spots here but that
and you think about how we attribute the
value of anything in our lives through
contrast and
in which the context in which we see it
so if you put
i talk about this in my book as well if
you put three tvs on a wall in an
electronic shop
people will think the most expensive tv
is
too expensive and too bougie they'll
think the cheapest tv
is probably gonna break and not very
good so typically they go for the middle
one
whereas if you remove them the two in
which you
the two next to it then they make
different decisions and you've seen this
with like ash's paradigm and you see it
on menus and
the way that we attribute the value like
i would be the prettiest
richest most successful person on planet
earth
if there was nobody else on earth
because it's all a measure of comparison
and instagram is a billion people
measure of comparison
where do i rank you've written about
this in yeah yeah yeah
i'll give you my book yeah yeah i'm
gonna read it
was it how to be a happy millionaire no
it's the title is happy sexy
millionaires and i'm i'm kind of
trying to instagram people instagram
bait people into buying the book right
right right
because much of buying books is
virtually signaling you know you're
right
right so the other thing that intrigued
me on the way here today was listening
to the podcast where you say
this is my podcast you know i'm slightly
embarrassed about don't tell anyone
about it whatever you do yeah
you know i would never have i would
never have thought of that as a way of
having a handle on the part i love that
absolutely loved it
but it's in funny kind of way it's kind
of like as a parent
it's a bit like reverse psychology
vegetables
what getting your kids to eat vegetables
yeah yeah but but you know i think the
true
the truth of human psychology probably
you know i mean you mentioned ashley hey
by the way
you know on psychology and on on the
global reach of twitter you talked about
ash's conformity
uh experiment that's that varies
systematically around the world
so so uh in in western countries
more individualistic countries people
deviate more
from the herd and explain what that is
because yes so um
if i if you're thinking of the same
experiment the lines yeah
yeah so so solomon ash one of the most
famous experiments in
in modern psychology he um
drew a number of vertical lines
um uh which were of
the same length and then a fifth line
that was significantly different in
length to the other four
and then he got people to answer the
question do you think these
i think i've got this broadly right do
you think all of these lines are of the
same length
and if you have people answering that on
their own like 99
say the fifth line is of a different
length to the other four but what ash
did
is he got you know 10 confederates to
come in and say oh they're the same
and then oh they're the same and then
the third person oh yeah they're the
same length and the fourth person
they're the same name
then when it gets to the actual subject
of the experiment they're like oh my
goodness if all these people think that
it must be the same and so they say yeah
they're all the same so they're
effectively
disbelieving the evidence of their own
eyes in order to fit in with the
crowd now that conformity bias which
surprises all the people
is stronger in other parts of the world
than it is in in
western can i just add as well on these
lines when you see these lines
there is no possible way that that small
line
is anywhere near the size of the other
lines but as you say because of
conformity these
these participants just go along with it
and it just it's just beggar's belief
that
that's how human psychology works but
there is a good reason for it if you
think about it
i mean every now well is there a i mean
there's a number of different theories
about why it happens but one of them is
that occasionally
um one can get things wrong that seem
obvious
and if there's a lot of people who are
independently saying the same thing
that's
very good evidence of what they're
saying is true um and so humans i think
that
bias evolved probably to enable us to
take advantage of the wisdom of the
crowd
but crowds if they can i mean crowds can
converge on things
incorrectly but not independently of it
so if you imagine a stock market bubble
that's one person buying another one
seeing that person buying and then
another person seeing those two buying
and they get a bandwagon effect whereas
if
10 people independently say that these
two lines are different
and you have no reason to believe that
they're lying that's a good reason to
start doubting so i think there
but but you know the reason i mentioned
it is there is this global systematic
variation in psychology so you may have
heard of
uh something called the fundamental
attribution error
um where we tend to blame people for
things that are
things have gone wrong because of the
situation that's much stronger in the
west than it is in the rest of the world
cognitive dissonance varies
fundamentally even
visual illusions um vary around the
world
and the reason i mention that is i think
it's helpful for businesses to
understand it but i think it actually
reaches into our deep history
and how human societies evolve which
which is the topic of my next bible i
thought you might be interested
in that okay so you guys know how much i
talk about huel and how much sure has
changed my life and also
how hewlett is the reason why much of
the reason why i'm in the best shape of
my life i definitely think that if i
hadn't had heal ready to drink
i would not be in the shape that i am
and i'm stronger than i've ever been
maybe two times stronger than i've ever
been
but what i want to talk to you about
today is hughes brand new
product which is just launched last week
which is the hule
protein and he would have never had a
protein product
but i was actually slightly involved in
the testing of this product
and it's amazing so i have pretty much
all the new flavors here
and my favorite flavor as always if you
know me you'll know this and a lot of
people send me this in my dms a salted
caramel
if you're looking to increase the
protein intake in your diet
and you're thinking about getting in
great shape
over the coming months which i think a
lot of people are then i would highly
recommend you try
the salted caramel fuel protein why try
that
100 calories per serving which is
staggering
20 grams of protein and it's got like 26
of your minerals and vitamins that you
need to function
and have a healthy body it's also vegan
and dairy-free
it's also gluten-free no artificial
colorings like a lot of protein products
have and no artificial flavorings at all
that is the heel way to make
nutritionally complete good food for you
give it a try send me your snapchats
instagrams tweets whatever you do if you
try it
and also send me your progress because i
i get so many dms now from people that
are taking huel
and that have seen significant changes
in their life um and it fills me with
joy that i get to talk about a product
on this podcast every week that
you guys love back to the podcast
one thing i i certainly do want to talk
to you about as well is how
as an individual because we've talked a
lot about companies um
and teams how as an individual one is to
reach
that this is a super broad question and
i hate asking broad questions because
you tend to get broad answers but
how has an individual one could reach
their potential or what what are
some of the fundamental things that
block people from reaching
their potential we've talked about a
fear of failure um
we've also touched on the idea that
people don't start because of that fear
of failure and they don't
get the feedback loops but what are the
other common sort of threads that you
see in
the reason why people never get near
their potential in life
so so in addition to those things so
fixed mindset fear of failure
risk adversely all the things we've
addressed the other thing i think is
i've become more interested in
it's related to what we've said but i
think it's different is is
what you might call initiative or agency
or proactivity i remember having an idea
this is in the 1970s early 1980s i was
going to table tennis competitions and
carrying this very heavy bag
blue holdall ascot hodl and thinking my
goodness this is really doing my backing
and it was just retrospectively obvious
that the solution to a problem that many
people had who are traveling a lot
is to put wheels on luggage
right wheeled suitcases which we all
have now
but having the idea doesn't mean a thing
you've actually got to act on that idea
right you've got to
say right i'm going to try and design
something i'm going to try and sell it
to a department store
i'm going to try and market it i'm going
to try and buy a shop i'm going to have
to pay
rent i have to go to the bank and get
some debt
that is a there is a massive difference
between a dormant
passive idea and one that you act upon
another example i lived on richmond on a
road in richmond
when i first moved there in my mid-20s
and it had no off street parking
what i didn't realize is that enrichment
parking is a nightmare
because all the houses have
less parking spaces than there are sorry
there are more there are less parking
spaces and there are houses and so
people park on the street and then
they get taken up but you end up having
to park 10 minutes away
a few doors down i notice at the top of
the road there's a
house with a parking space that is
always empty
i thought to myself i should knock on
the door or i should write them a note
and so i'm willing to pay rent or to buy
it from you
but i never got around to doing it and
then a few years later i was at a house
party
and this person said i used to live on
montague oh really that's interesting i
lived there too
he said yeah i had the house at the time
i said what with the parking space he
said yeah what i never understood is
that no one ever
came and asked whether they could rent
it and i thought that idea was in my
head and i never acted on it
why because there is a there's a
fundamental
inertia in a lot of us between you know
it's easy to have an idea it takes a bit
of
you know i remember when i was injured
in table tennis and you know i wasn't
practicing i wasn't doing anything and i
sat at home you know just posting the
letter felt like an
unbelievably tough thing to do you have
to go all the way to the post office
by a stamp you know oh man it was like
i'm struggling you know
this this the psychologist i've got
interested in recently is a guy called
michael fraser he's a german
really interesting guy and he looked at
the unification of germany right after
the fall of the berlin wall and
you know the west german business like
this is fantastic we're gonna have this
pool of really keen workers
and it just didn't work out because the
east german
um generalizing a little but the east
german workers had
worked in in a communist system where
all the decisions are taken by the party
bosses
and so if a machine broke down instead
of taking action to fix it they would
just wait for
the boss person to come along and fix it
for them
if they needed the telephone number they
would wait and they wouldn't act on it
and i think that being able to richard
branson
you probably know i mean i got to know
little you know he talked about how i
mean i think this is probably
well he this is the way he tells it you
know virgin atlantic he he was flying
to the british virgin islands uh to meet
his girlfriend
uh he has a stopover in miami uh
they're bumped off the flight they delay
it to the next day and everyone sat
there going this this is a disaster
then he thought well hang on a second i
could charter a private plane
which were which were in the airport so
he took the initiative probably a few
people had that idea what about
chartering a private plane
but he actually picked up the phone and
said right how much will it cost to
charter a plane you know
ten thousand dollars he then went around
to all the people with a blackboard
saying version you know
flight this is the amount per ticket
some people
bought it they managed to take the
flight and then when he got home he
rented a
boeing and and went from there and i
think that proactivity
is absolutely critical
you go to school for all those years you
get to 16.
but what about going out there and
you're about to take a decision about
what your future career will be
you know in my day when you came out
university some people would be in the
same career for life
and you take that decision without going
in asking people what was it like in
this job
could i perhaps work for a day in this
job a lot of people i went to university
with took
jobs without any of that proactive
analysis
of what it would be like now you as an
entrepreneur have this in spades
i want more entrepreneurship in schools
i want proactivity
instead of learning business studies
concepts
this is another experiment by michael
fraser instead of people doing an mba
he gave them a short course on
converting ideas into action
he calls it the action cycle those
entrepreneurs compared to a control
group
uh you know had you know 25 i can't
remember the exact amount but five times
more successful businesses or twenty
percent higher profits it was
uh published in science magazine so you
know i think that's a really really big
deal
that's a mindset i just can't get over
this idea that you saw that that car
parking space and you know you didn't
you didn't knock on or send a letter and
i'm trying to understand linked also to
um what you then talked about with
richard branson at that airport with the
with the blackboard going around and
trying to sell this airline that he'd
just come up with what is the
mental like cultural mental
psychological difference between the
people that sat there and thought i'm
just going to accept
this situation as is like you did with
the driveway or like the
other passengers who had just been
cancelled did
and the person that takes the initiative
what is it about them and what is
blocking i guess the better question is
what is blocking those
that are sat there on the airport floor
thinking [ __ ] i'm my life is over
um or i can't find a car parking space
what is blocking them and
is it this is my hypothesis there's some
kind of mental equation we're all doing
very very quickly
that's weighing up the effort it would
take and also our perceived outcome of
success our perceived chance of success
in endeavor
um and and coming to the conclusion that
it's
just not worth it or possible i don't
think that's what i i
i would reject that hypothesis i don't
think people make a rational calculation
i think it's more habit
once you're used to doing things once
if you've been at a school where and
some people are lucky enough to go to
school
where you are encouraged to to make
things happen
to you know some schools you know they
are actually asked to start a business
to pick up the phone to to um
to engage with other people as they seek
to do something you begin to
it becomes a habit the idea of writing a
letter and dropping it's like no big
deal that isn't a barrier for me it
becomes a
it becomes second nature i can tell you
from this parking space i was
you know i was just in a it was just
pure inertia i hadn't learned that
entrepreneurial mindset i did i mean
that took me a long time to learn as
well
and you think i'm just thinking about
how i would teach someone
to take be proactive i i so for i i've
thought a lot about this too and i i
i think you get people to do it so what
fraser does
in his courses he keeps linking ideas to
action you're not allowed to have an
idea without acting upon it
he calls it the uh the active ingredient
so you get into a habit of so so one uh
uh uh one of the entrepreneurs so so
he's done these experiments in europe
and in africa
um but in one of i mean he tells great
stories about it but it's
such a long time since i read the papers
um
so i think habit doing it again and
again and again you begin to get into
the routine
of linking ideas to action i i honestly
i think we shouldn't underestimate how
damaging it can be if we if we just
continue to go
with the flow and we're not prepared to
to break it from time to time
then you're kind of just a puppet to the
course of life i guess in some respects
right and i think uh yeah i think there
are
a lot of people with truly brilliant
ideas
huge potential who never
act on their dreams you had the dream
but
think about your dream that would remain
dormant
in your head had you not acted these are
distinct phenomena the idea
and the action you can have ideas and
dreams without acting on them i just
my yeah so i get a lot of dms from
people you can imagine the dm's are i've
got a great idea
and you know that 99 of people you speak
to
are never going to do anything about it
because right the the hardest part is
is doing it's just day one it's like
think of the name of the company but
they they just well i call them
sofapreneurs they have the idea on the
sofa
it never makes it a part of the sofa and
that's like 99 of people and i i wonder
what the barrier is between like
starting i i sometimes hypothesize that
it's because of this culture of
perfectionism
and this culture of needing to start at
a perfect point with all the resources
all the knowledge all the contacts the
right team which is not the case
i mean if you look at how ben francis
started his business where i started
mine it's
googling on a computer how do you build
a website and doing that for three
months
um but i but i always i always wonder i
think we could we would we would unlock
so much potential
if we were able to get people just to
the starting blocks
and we can't they're all on their sofas
yeah and and
yeah i i yeah i you describe it
brilliantly
um a couple of things that might be
worth throwing in there's a guy called
mike barton he was chief constable of of
durham police and he kept getting rated
the highest by the independent inspector
of the constabulary and i
remember i was really intrigued by this
so i i talked to him and met him
and he said that if he could
he would ask every wannabe police
officer to take one year off to start a
business
and for it to fail or to succeed just so
they started learning
using their own initiative because that
is what great policing is about
um stanley mcchrystal stanley mcchrystal
was the head of the task force in iraq
after the invasion that were trying to
quell the
insurgency of al-qaeda and at the time
it was a real
you know it's a top-down model people at
the bottom were passive
if they wanted to get anything done they
had to go up the chain of command get
sign off and it would go back down
so lacking agility and not really using
their brains
and he pushed authority down the chain
of command people could do
they could as it were initiate action
against al-qaeda targets if they thought
it was sensible to do so
and it had a big big effect on the
success of the army the number of
operations but also the percentage of
successful operations
so i think that you know i think there's
a lot of different people who are
who are working along the lines that
we're talking about right now but for me
education is a key and i'd like to see
more work done in schools to really
equip young people with this active
ingredient
you've written i think we said six books
right six books now
um they they center around topics like
high performance and mindset
and and the like um what's the biggest
thing that you're a contradiction on
in terms of what you can write about and
know and and profess to the world
but then you struggle with in your
personal life
to implement that's a great question
that's a great question i've never been
asked that before so
one of the things i'm thinking so so i i
you know
write newspaper columns all right sports
column for the times
and the political column for the sunday
times right and and i think
one thing that i try to do is read
other people who disagree with me
because that's a really useful thing
because either you really understand why
you think they're wrong or you realize
there's a weakness in your own
argument but now i think about i think
the last fortnight i haven't
i haven't been doing that enough so i
must remember that as a discipline to
to constantly read those sources that i
know are going to be
different i've got a question for you by
the way so this is another one that i'm
thinking about a lot
um what do you what did what's your view
of the word
woke so if you're if you're my age that
you know
people what your cancer culture yeah
um is that a good thing or about which
which which
part so i mean i was actually funnily
enough i was listening to
pierce morgan um talk about the word
woke last night
oh yeah it was like a 16 minutes
australia
interview and i don't know why it just
came up in my i watched 60 minutes
australia because i'm in the algorithm
so i'm in the echo chamber so it's
serving it to me every day
and he's done an interview in the last
24 hours regarding meghan markle and
explaining
you know he's being a bit of a crusader
now saying i was cancelled for standing
up for my opinions he's like really
going for it now
um and so
i don't really want to get in the
definitions because then people are just
gonna but so cancer culture
i think is a bad thing because i think
i mean we saw one yesterday where the
qriket player
who said some very you know racist
things 10 years ago when he was a
teenager
has now been suspended from the england
cricket team 10 years later
he said a couple of things you know
about you know he said something
yeah i don't want to repeat that because
someone's going to click on the daily
that's my column
is that what you're writing about yeah i
mean i it's racist i'm a person of color
and i think it's ridiculous that he was
cancelled
yeah he said some stupid jokes some
stupid slightly racist jokes 10 years
ago
are we really going to create a culture
where we're going to rid him of his
livelihood
for some stupid tweets when he was a
teenager because i tell you what i don't
know a single human being that's not
cracked a slightly inappropriate
either slash partly racist joke in their
lifetime
and this idea that publicly we're all
angels
perfect angels who are here to judge
others to the same standard of false
perfection that we portray is just like
deeply toxic and then also
we're now on the on the idea of like
free speech
we're now stopping the best ideas
because we're judging them based on
whether they fit or not
and this is again we talked about
divergent thinking and thinking having
more diverse thoughts and accepting them
and welcoming them and
interrogating them for their merit not
whether they fit
i think is is awful and my last point
again is um there's been a couple of
moments
black lives matter some other issues
where i've my opinion
has been in neither camp and
i you it's just you know
totally unacceptable because i would so
black lives matter issue i did a post
you know the narrative was if you don't
speak out then you're a racist silence
is violence
and after um george floyd was was
tragically murdered i did a post saying
listen
people process traumatic events in
various different ways
some just going to social media and
posting about it isn't actually a very
human way to process trauma
so if someone isn't speaking it doesn't
make them a racist and also you know
and and and the problem with the
thinking there is
people will look at your opinion and say
he's not wearing our football kit
he must be one of them and because he's
not wearing our football kit the socks
the shoes the shorts the shirt
he must therefore believe all of the
things that the right believe
and they put you and it's so binary you
there's no appreciation or space for
nuance
it's not the way to get to the best
ideas right look i i i'm really glad to
hear you say all that i agree with
everything you said and i'll add one
other thing
so i concur with all of those three
points i think they're very powerful
um the other thing i'm from a half
pakistani half wealth background you
know so i've
had the p word a lot in the 70s and 80s
and
i'm sensitive to to racial
discrimination
i saw my father not get from a
brilliantly talented person not get
promoted because of its color
um and that you know it leaves a real
scar
on someone growing up the other thing is
i think it's a complete absence of an
analysis of how to improve
the lives of people from ethnic
minorities um
cancelling somebody who sent a tweet
nine years ago in their formative years
it is almost like a fig leaf for true
action
civil rights movement was a great thing
in america in my opinion martin luther
king
the civil rights act the voting rights
act
but i think we have to acknowledge that
it hasn't achieved many of its most
basic objectives if you look at the
number of
black people in prison the education gap
the income and wealth gaps
i think there's a real empirical
question
about what we do and it's not going to
help
those massively important demographic
statistics yeah
to cancel somebody and it's it's almost
like it's a
it's a it's a surrender when we should
be doing things that can have a tangible
effect
this is what my my post said it was nine
slides long or nine
tweet threads and the conclusive point
was i'm going to be black forever
so if you want to help me and my my
future kids and my kids kids
a black tile on instagram or a hashtag
doesn't actually address the problem
canceling someone telling organizations
they need to donate doesn't actually
help the problem if you
really cared if your care was genuine
and not
survival oriented or virtue signaling
orientated you'd probably be
thinking about systemic issues and you
can't capture or you know
or you'd be reading or educating
yourself which are all things that
won't take place in the public forum so
go at the systemic stuff or
you know educate yourself that that to
me feels like a more genuine way to
change things yeah hashtags black tiles
canceling does it just seems like
you're ephemera you care more about
yourself
right um it's kind of not it's a kind of
uh it's a kind of narcissism i think or
at its worst it can be that yeah the
people react to that post
do you know what on that particular one
everyone agreed and that's crazy because
no one was saying it
and it's like it because i'm a black guy
it was like i gave them space to
disagree so it was actually on instagram
it did 600
000 likes wow which is a lot of likes
right
it did hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of records
it's one of my best i think one of my
best performing posts ever and it was
funny because you had like i don't know
three black people in my
in the comments section being like yeah
yeah i meant to be like
angry at me but then when i'd asked them
i'd say which one of these
um the slides do you disagree with and
tell me the sentence you disagree with
you can't find something you disagree
with in the post it's the sentiment
that this is not the party line yeah
by the way one other thing the wisdom um
the cricket magazine wisdom.com
have managed to find a post from an
england player
that was controversial i think racist or
or misogynistic
but before they were 16 years of age so
they haven't published the name yet
but can you imagine if that person was
suspended
for for something they said when they
were effectively a child
because we we talked about failure if
anyone who aspires to the england
cricket team
never says anything publicly never
writes a school essay that might come
back to haunt them
you know you never the way we learn is
by saying things
and then being challenged you don't lose
all of that if you basically
just either toe the party line
or say nothing at all that's a that
would be a catastrophe for
a dynamic liberal society imagine
that all the progress that would have
been lost right had people not stepped
outside of a party line
and instead you know stood on top of
podiums and made speeches that
people disagreed with and got them
stoned and shot and
i mean that's where most progress seems
to come from it seems to come from an
outlier
well that's right and and you know i
mean it might sound old-fashioned to say
this but you know jon stewart mill
um locke the founding fathers in the
united
states what used to be called the
western miracle
you know the fact that economic growth
was was very close to zero percent
for the first two million years of uh
the
species to which we belong right i mean
it was very very tiny throughout our
history you know somebody who was born
in
if 2000 years ago and somebody was born
1500 years ago would have seen very
little change in
society and then economic growth started
taking off
in the 18th century and now obviously
it's doubled and trebled and quadrupled
and
we expect growth to be two to three
percent a year and if it's
if we have two consecutive quarters of
negative growth we call it a recession
one of the reasons that happened is
because of exactly what you say
people were freed from the constraints
of the
party line you could say something
that for example the religious
authorities didn't approve of that the
sun is the center of the solar system
not the earth you can test hypotheses
you can say the world is older than 6
000
years you start to adapt your
understanding of the world that's
science that's technology
and i think the more construct you know
now free speech doesn't seem fashionable
these days
but those ideas in addition by the way
to things like due process
the thing that has made me trend the
only time i think i've ever trended on
twitter
is when i defended due pro so the idea
that in order to be punished for
something
you have to have had some kind of an
independent
process some independent tribunal to
establish
having listened to different sides of
the argument whether the
crime had taken place now that again is
something that takes
societies a long time to create a
an independent rule of law you know
judiciary that's in
and and people were like that's
outrageous because i was defending
somebody who had been accused of a
racist remark
and i said yeah racism is wrong but
let's wait for the process before this
person is sacked
the implication was i was defending
racism itself but that is not the same
thing but i
worry a bit that we're losing that uh
that distinction i think there's certain
people fighting back
yeah yeah and that'll be maybe it'll
swing back the other way yeah i hope so
i i i would hope so too um
self-belief i'm very intrigued as to
um you know some certain people in our
society
are more self-believing than others um
you see differences in
um genders and races and and
backgrounds and i think a lot of people
in my dms i'm
and this is where the question comes
from i have so many young kids in my
my dms that are struggling with um
confidence or
lacking self-belief and i wondered if
you had
any words of wisdom for those in my dms
that
can't find confidence and self-belief
i think for what it's worth
that self-belief self-esteem
other things of that kind of overrated
um and the reason goes back to something
we said earlier i mean there was a
movement in the 70s and 80s in
western education to build self-esteem
in young people and the way to do it was
to let them succeed all the time
right so you won't remember this but it
would you give them easy tests
get them to pass and give them lots of
and then praise them for how super
talented they were they get all this
self-esteem and they can change the
world
people were so worried about undermining
self-esteem that there were no losers in
sports days at some schools
i don't know if you have you heard of
this everyone's a winner yeah everyone
gets a sticker
and that was all about building it was
called the self-esteem movement
right but it failed and the reason it
failed
is because people would keep succeeding
and you know they'd get all this
self-esteem
and then then they'd be given a
difficult test
right or they would leave school and
they'd actually
hit the real world where they would fail
and what happened
all the walls of their world would come
crumbling down oh my goodness
i've never felt before right self-esteem
that is frag and people would protect
their self-esteem by not trying new
things
right and and that's a disaster
self-esteem can be very fragile i i like
to talk much more about resilience
we want people we i want my children to
be resilient
to try new things to mess up but not to
be devastated by it
and that i think is a much better
quality now it may be that when people
are talking about confidence what they
really mean is resilience
i want to be able to walk into a room
give it my best shot things don't
go slightly wrong i'm going to carry on
regardless every person who's a success
has had some really tough difficult
moments
and i just think that's an inevitable
part of learning how do we build
resilience in ourselves
growth mindset is very strongly related
to it so instead of
um you know for parents out there i
don't you probably have a very young
audience
i'm showing myself but but uh the
parents out there it's very easy to
praise
young people for their talent you're
super
they've just drawn a picture you're
super talented you're the next picasso
you think they're going to develop all
this self-esteem
the problem as i've said is that you
know the moment they draw something that
isn't picasso
as soon as they get negative criticism
oh my goodness i'm no picasso after all
um much better thing to do is to praise
them for the
effort or the process well i love the
way that picture
that the colors fit together they think
oh right if i want to develop as a
painter i have to make the colors fit
together in a more sophisticated way
you're aligning their mind and
motivation
with the journey they need to take to
fulfill their potential
so it's good experiments praising for
effort praising for process
is a much more um positive thing than
praising for talent
and fixed attributes it's interesting
because in my company i
came to learn that um the most effective
way to get my teams to innovate was to
praise them for the effort and the
process as opposed to the outcome
because if it became about the outcome
the successful failure of the experiment
then um which is largely actually
outside of their control
right when you're doing so if i say to
my team right we're going to build this
website and we think it's going to do
this
whether it does that or not whether this
product market fit whether it's a
success or a failure isn't actually in
their control the bit they can control
is
starting doing it and the process of
getting to the point where we press
go live and so we what i learned in the
last year of my business was we would
celebrate
the um conducting the experiment not the
outcome of the experiment
exactly right actually that is exactly
the same thing
and it's interesting that if you look at
r d you know um
have you had a six sigma yes yeah so so
one of the things i mean one of the big
massive i mean six sigma is a great
process
you know like lean manufacturing or um
uh
uh your toilet pro things of that kind
it's basically squeezing out variation
isn't it so if you imagine making a car
or you know manufacturing car all it
takes is one component in the engine to
be of the wrong size or specification
and the whole thing won't work
so six sigma is about delivering and
executing with no variation
but when you're innovating you need
variation you need to try new things
if you're trying to create a new
computer program a new website or
a new drug and you don't know which
combination of ingredients they're going
to create it you need to try lots of
combinations
if you penalize people for failure oh my
god and you're only
judging them on the outcome and it fails
and then they're like stigmatized they
will never try
you need you know that's where failed
fast car yeah you've nailed it that's
exactly the insight that i think is
is is important and i guess the last
thing i want to talk to you about is
leadership um and how to how one can
become
a better leader in whatever field of
life you're
you're in whether it's sports or whether
it's business like me
um what are the attributes of successful
leaders
well i i think um
i think it's a very difficult job
leadership yeah of course it's extremely
difficult i don't know if you'd agree
with this but i do think
even in a psychologically safe you know
where people can speak up
a leader still needs to make the
decision i think it it can often lead to
confusion over who's in charge if it's a
completely democratic organization oh
god
yeah you need leadership so i believe my
own view
based on evidence is that you need
social hierarchies in order for
organizations institutions and societies
to succeed
but you want those hierarchies to work
so leadership i don't think you can
outsource it
you need to make judgments you need to
take ownership of those judgments
but i think if i had to say one thing
okay i'll give you my
and this is based on knowing a lot of
like you know many many leaders in lots
of different contexts over a long period
of time i think the best leaders
have a hybrid approach to leadership
okay and what i mean by that
is when you're evaluating
what we should do next you need to be
humble
you need to encourage different ideas
and you need not to be threatened
when people dissent because that
encourages
people to speak up but when you've made
a decision
and you've found the destination and
you're going for it
i think you need to then have confidence
and you know you need to galvanize
that's where charisma comes to the fore
when you articulate the mission
because at that point having different
ideas you know you're already on the way
that can often be quite disrupt i mean
obviously you do need to change the
trajectory if
you know something but i think that and
funny enough in sport you see
so humility and evaluation confidence
and execution
it's the same in sport so
if you imagine you're a surgeon or or in
surgery if
if you're humble at the time you wield
the scalpel this might go wrong i don't
know everything you know
your hand's gonna be if you're tiger
woods on the 18th you want to be
absolutely confident when you take the
pup
execution but then if the surgeon says
i'm a genius i'm brilliant you know i'm
confident i don't need to learn they'll
never evaluate what happened and
therefore won't improve
i'll tell you what made me think i want
some ghosted david it's like a fixed
mindset right complacency creeps in and
you two say that again we're talking
about the surgeon that's
sure there right and it's the fixed
mindset analogy you made
right and then complacency creeps in
it's a disaster because what you want to
do after a
surgical procedure is review it
in a completely honest way so you can
find out things that you did wrong and
could improve
but if you have utter self-confidence i
don't need to improve that's exactly as
you say a fixed mindset response you
don't improve through time
beckham i ghosted his autobiography a
few years ago
and he told me about when he took the
free kick against greece
how old are you by the way 28 so you
won't even
you won't remember this i remember i
would never forget
two it was the world cup qualifiers and
he ran to the left corner i'll never
forget that's right
that's right so his extra time he needed
a score to get through
and teddy's sharing him trying to take
the ball and you see on the video
beckham snapped
and he said when i took that freak i was
a hundred percent i was going to make it
that's
a useful thing to have right but you
meet beckham
away on the training pitch the humility
i need to improve the way i take free
kicks i need to look at the things that
went wrong in the previous game i need
to
just see that so leaders need to be both
humble
and confident depending on where they
are on the performance side
when they're out there executing
confidence
when they're evaluating reviewing
humility i think most of the best
leaders have it
you know sachin adela at microsoft is a
great example of that
humble you know their market cap has
grown over a trillion dollars since he
took over
you know very humble person i've met him
a number of times great great person
but there is confidence when he's
galvanizing his team towards a decision
that
they've debated and discussed i think
that's so true i was just running
through all the great leaders that i
know
and those um those attributes seem to be
there
even you know a good example is sir alex
ferguson ria ferdinand sat in the chair
and he told me that sir alex ferguson is
obviously known for the hairdryer and
being
very clear on what he wants but then if
so ria went to sir alex ferguson after a
game
and said you know you didn't support my
brother
anton got racially abused and then rio
wore a shirt in protest of it
alex sir alex ferguson was really angry
rio went to him after
the game and had a chat with him and
alex alex admitted he was wrong
yeah and held his hands up and i somehow
managed to make it up to rio within a
couple of words
but you know that's that's right that's
exactly right that's
but it goes with with ferguson he always
hired
constantly you know assistant managers
who challenged his perspective
you know uh carlos quiroz
mike phelan mullenstein mclaren
he also would often do competitions
for his players to guess who would be in
the opposition team
he would go to other clubs and watch the
way they trained
ferguson came from from govan from a
very working-class background he never
lost his capacity to learn
never and he was always had a certain
level of humility but once they were out
there and performing
he was incredibly self-confident and i
don't think that's a contradiction
interesting it makes me kind of
reflecting then on
how important it is to be curious
throughout your life
even when new technology like social
media pops up and you
you're a little bit disoriented by it
and i see that in
really great successful leaders that i
know in my life business owners ceos
the ones that are the most curious um
tend to have the best long-term outcomes
and longevity
and i think it's hard to teach curiosity
um
i do i do wonder myself because
obviously i made my money off social
media
and even now i'm getting too old for
that are you still working in the
business no
i'm not working in the business anymore
now i've resigned at the end of last
year
so now i'm a free agent working on a new
business but in a similar industry
slightly different um much bigger
ambition um i guess and i'm working
across multiple industries so i'm like
working in a
psychedelics biotech firm that's about
to list for
you know several billion dollars i'm
working huel i'm on the board there and
work with that team i'm working in
a variety of different companies all
around the world that are in mental
health
consumer goods social media um
you know and i think i've done that as
well because i
as i talk about my book i want to like
resist my labels i want to stay curious
i want to stay
emerged in worlds that i don't know i'm
working on a blockchain company at the
moment
which is web 3.0 using ethereum and
smart contracts
and it's my i like being diverse in my
thinking because i actually think that's
where creativity comes from in a weird
way
and the one of the things that enables
me to have this podcast is i have a very
diverse view of the world and a
very diverse view of organizations and
people and that will make me good at
it sounds like a crazy thing to say like
we're putting on a theatrical show
in manchester sold out it's like this
it's called the diversio live there's a
big choir all this all these
really amazing things and when i look at
that show what it is it's a culmination
it's a very very different show but it's
a culmination of all these random
experiences i had in my life
going to the theater for the first time
listening to a choir watching kanye west
um a light show i saw and all of these
little things and so i think
you know i mean you you write about it
you talk about diversity of
ideas i'm going to send you a copy so my
latest book well a couple years ago now
was
called the power of rebel idea is a
power of diverse thinking i'm going to
send you a copy
i want to have a copy of your book i'm
going to read it i'm going to read it
this week
oh wow that's fast well how many words
is it is it very long
no no no no 17
000. 70. no no 55 000
yeah yeah okay it's interesting you'll
be particularly intrigued by i think by
the first couple of chapters which focus
on
social media the world we're living in
keeping up with kardashians generation
et cetera et cetera well i've got to say
uh you know i know we're coming to
another you are you're exceptionally
articulate
oh that's a huge compliment so i i kind
of you know
i uh i'm interested in that because
i think um you know i definitely didn't
have that when i was at school i
wasn't able really to put sentences
together you should do a podcast you
just have the most amazing voice
i've got to tell you my brother found an
old tape of me being interviewed as a 15
year old
[Music]
when i got selected for a national team
i just really start i think we
need more of that learning how to you
know communication is so important
getting our ideas across so that
somebody can understand
not just what we say but what we mean
yeah and i think that's a
i think that's a radically learnable
skill you know a lot of the top
speakers have practiced it youtube aside
it's one that's in
decline because of screens typing
well yeah that's true yeah yeah yeah you
have to talk to each other anymore yeah
zoom anyway listen thank you so much for
your time it's been such a pleasure to
to meet you you're you're i mean you're
an individual that's had such a
tremendous impact on
the thinking especially of people in the
professional but also self-development
world i remember reading your book
a long time ago on a plane bounce and
how intrigued i was by
um the emphasis you put on this growth
mindset and practice and
being teachable and your your your where
you are in life not being
set in stone if you're willing to put in
the work and practice and
um yeah i mean my team here are also
huge fans of yours matt over there's
read all your books
and he he'll read them in 24 hours this
is this guy's a monster
thank you
and good luck with it i'm going to
follow you with huge interest
from from now on and uh you're about to
hit the main stream aren't you
dragonstone hasn't been brought
yeah good luck thank you
[Music]
foreign